six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's go to our next caller
from the eighth 1/2 area code caller
from eight one two what's going on today
hi David Sam from Denver how you doing
good what's going on I want to know
where you disagree with me on three
things I think currently we are at the
end of a business cycle that the Trump
bump is a bubble because it's not real
earnings and I believe that the
government shutdown made papads and I
want to know where you would disagree
with me and how important what
disagreements would be okay well let's
take them one at a time number one I
have said for years that after one of
the biggest stock market run ups and
real estate run ups in history in the
United States at some point the cycles
take place and we've sort of been
wondering when that's going to come I
think that that is separate from whether
Donald Trump's policies exacerbate or
slow that down or impact it one way or
the other so yes I don't know that I
would call it a business cycle but
there's absolutely no question that we
have been wondering when the next
downturn would be and it may be
happening now number two as far as the
Trump bump I actually don't really know
what you're talking about
other than if you mean the stock market
run up many of whose gains were given
back during 2018 a year that stocks
decline so what did you mean by the
Trump bump well if you look at just the
indexes after Trump one it looks like
they were very skeptical during the
election and just started rocketing up
in a way that generally the markets
don't seem to and now we see this
whipsaw yeah right I mean so I guess in
that sense I agree which is that a lot
of the 2017 gains were given back in
2018 and I do think that it was just a
temporary fluctuation the most
interesting element you brought up is
whether the the government shutdown
could pop the bubble and I think the
answer is yes if it goes on long enough
and it's starting to get to the point
now where I think I read that the
average amount of wages that federal
employees affected by the shutdown have
now miss
doubt on is Phi or that are owed is
about $5,000 in gross income and this
can only go on for so long before it
does start to have more significant
economic impact now 800,000 employees
and a few million contractors in a
country of 340 million it's still a
relatively small percentage of the
population but you are now starting to
talk not only about those individuals
ability to have money which they can
spend in the economy you're also talking
about all of the work that every single
one of the shutdown agencies does that
allows the economy to continue
functioning and full so yes I do believe
that if the shutdown goes on
significantly longer that it's going to
have a macroeconomic impact for sure all
right well thanks for your insights
David and thanks your work thank you
appreciate the phone call